[Applause]
because he does choreography he does
he's so good okay welcome back we were
just talking about justin bieber and
during the break like justin bieber i
mean nobody on planet earth i know right
justin bieber if you're watching this
you're my favorite singer we all have
bieber fever beaver fever
the believers i get we are are you a
believer i've got to be yes
um well we are beliebers of toys um and
our toy expert maddie maholick was
giving us the scoop on all the toys we
need to have for the summer um
for fun in the sun and our dear friend
of the show
uh leo kelly is here giving us his
thoughts on the toys now maddie what do
we have next all right so we're going to
talk about swinging shoes
now this is a really fun game that you
can play inside or outside no matter
what the weather is so this is a new
take on the classic game of horseshoes
but here's the twist it is suspended in
the air either from a tree or your door
frame so as you are
uh getting your horseshoes on the
platform it's going to be moving so it's
extra challenging you guys want to give
it a try yes please here are your
horseshoes the good thing about these
are they're not like 500 pounds and
they're not made of metal they're
rubbery
very kid-friendly everyone can play i
hear you there if they hit your head
they don't hurt all right are you guys
ready to go yeah
you want to go first no you could go
oh nice
oh good job yes
there you go leo so you can land i'm
making this one for you i'm making this
one for drew so it's even
oh wait did i just knock that other one
off no you got it it's still there okay
i will say this this game is totally
addictive it is expensive yeah you just
want to keep going you're like the next
time i'm getting it oh my god okay
all right oh god leo you did it it's
okay oh darn it okay what is our last
summer item
[Applause]
yeah so there's no such thing as summer
fun without a nice refreshing icee
but now you can make it in your own home
with this icy machine maker that is so
cool all you do is add water your
favorite flavor of syrup and some ice
and then you have the perfect slushie
every time i mean leo kelly you are the
shirley temple king what are your
thoughts on yes we have a special made
for you yes i mean it literally is let's
try it we're gonna cheers to the summer
guys let's go buddy thank you so much
what do you think leo this is so good
thanks to
toy insider you're all gonna go home
with everything that you see here
today so
i hope
that you guys enjoy your eight foot
dress and um we can all use a little
light a little fun a little sun a little
magic little toys we all deserve this so
thank you toy insider and thank you
maddie maholick thank you for doing that
thank you for playing today and leo
i love you so much
thank you everybody
for choosing to spend your time with us
because i promise you with all of my
heart we make this show with our heart
and we make it for you so please take it
with you
[Music]
you